mm 18 marks 25 years since the deadly
51-day standoff between the Branch
Davidian cult and the federal government
in Waco Texas
David Koresh was the charismatic leader
of the fringe religious group more than
80 people were killed over the course of
the siege including Koresh his followers
and federal agents for the first time a
retired UPS drivers revealing how he
unknowingly delivered weapons and
ammunition to the compound in the weeks
before the confrontation 48 hours Peter
Van Sant reveals the secrets from Waco
that haven't been told until now I've
kept my story secret for the last 25
years I didn't want to take this to my
grave this delivery man unwittingly
armed the cult I had been blamed what
happened out there
Waco was a tale of a religious fringe
group that decided to fight back against
the federal government their leader
David Koresh a self-proclaimed son of
God he was incredibly charismatic I
waited patiently on the Lord he was
spellbinding he was a God in the human
flesh they would do anything for this
man even unholy acts how many young
girls did he have sex with I'm thinking
at least him he was a Jesus Christ who
could drink and smoke and love guns and
rock and roll but he was going to bring
about the end of times they began buying
guns investigative journalist Lee
Hancock covered Koresh for more than two
decades she is a CBS News consultant my
mom made bulletproof vests Joanne Vega
moved into the compound with her parents
as a toddler they were getting shipments
from an arms dealer
the Davidian arms race turned more
ominous when larry was checking a box in
his truck and about six to eight grenade
fell out of it he told his wife Debra
somebody had to do something
Debra told the Sheriff's Department who
called the Federal Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms
the ATF we were all concerned about the
fact that there were children present
after two months of reconnaissance ATF
authorized arresting David Koresh and
confiscating any illegal weapons my mom
grabbed me off the bed there were people
lying on the floor that were dead
I took a flashbang and threw it in the
window when I get through the window
there's a man standing in the room with
an ak-47 and I shot him several times
seconds later
Buford like this agent was shot I'm not
gonna let him kill me in here Buford on
the hood of the vehicle was rescued by
fellow agents the FBI takes over after
51 days they began ramming the main
building the horror was unimaginable
there were people who killed one another
David Koresh actually had a bullet wound
into the center of his head Joann
Villegas parents died in the flames she
saved your life I think about that all
the time your mother saved you mm-hmm
when people see the names they're just
names I see faces I've never failed it
much in my life that I failed every day
it crosses my mind Peter Van Zandt joins
us now Peter millions of Americans
remember this siege what did
investigators learn about what was
happening inside the compound
there was a real horror show on the
inside they were restricted in terms of
the amount of food that they had Koresh
had decided that all of the women in the
compound were his and he began having
sex with girls as young as 14 years of
age it's believed he may have fathered
as many as 20 children with some of the
mothers being minors themselves so he
was he was
committing statutory rape on the inside
and you said that among the children who
died they were all his he allowed other
children to leave yeah it wasn't long
into the siege where he led about 21 of
these children leave but those inside
were his biological children that he
wanted to keep with them and tragically
that there may have been as many as two
dozen of them who perished in the fire
you see the pain on that UPS drivers
face that he has to live with this so
many years later we all remember those
images guy and he is a fantastic
individual who tells his story for the
first time on 48 hours fascinating we
will be watching Peter thank you so much
thank you and you can see Peters full
report the secrets of Waco tonight at
8:00 p.m. 7:00 central right here on CBS